house of gucci is best suited for an  audience in a theater seeing a movie in  a dark room with people that are  different from you it just elevates it  i'm happy to be part of a movie that is  meant to be experienced that way like  the phoenix gucci is born of death it's  not a typical ridley school film it's a  little bit bigger than life  and with the cast and every actor  you feel the weight of this glamorous  drama  when you go to a movie theater you have  a feeling you've been through something  this film was designed to be seen on the  big screen  the quality  of the image  of the sound  it is such a wild ride  and every second of it is entertaining  that's why you go to the movies  [Music]  [Music]